ذكر شهد عيان من عائله الخالدي ان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نفذت الجمعه الماضي
في حي الشيخ رضوان بمدينه غزه اعدامات
ميدانيه بحق سته اشخاص بينهم اربعه من
افراد اسرته وقال شاهد العيان ان قوات
الاحتلال داهمت منزل العائله في احد
المربعات السكنيه بحي الشيخ رضوان واعدمت
بدم بارد الاشخاص السته ومن دون سابق
انذار بدايه احنا كنا مخليين عند بيت احد
الاقارب في محيط مدارس الشيخ رضوان كانت
نايمين والامور كانت تمام فجاه الساعه
اتين في الليل صحينا على صوت انفجار واذ
به احد المنازل بجوارنا المنزل بجاور
بالتمام انفجر المنزل بالصاروخ فنزلنا على
الطابق
الارضي نزلنا نشوف ايش اللي صار مع
جيراننا وطلعنا منهم
الشهداء فجاه بعد بعد ما صلينا المغرب
سمعنا صوت ناس بتتكلم
العبريه دخلوا كان معهم الكشافات اللي على
الراس اول ما دخلوا حكوا في العبري كنا
احنا الشباب على
الحيطه كل الاصابات كله تخوننا بحث اصابات
ما حد في اللحظه هذه اول ما دخل كله
اصابات ما حد استشهد البنات والنسوان
كانوا في الغرفه المقابله صوتوا فالتف
الجيش
عليهم فكانت جدتي الله يرحمها ومرا ثانيه
كانوا على باب الغرفه ط
اخوهم فسيدي كان يتقن اللغه العبريه حكى
للنسوان اللي معنا اسمعوا ايش حيقول لكم
الجيش لانه في الجيش ما حد حكىا في العربي
نهائيا لفوا وجههم على سيدي طقوا ابوي
اللي كان
جنبيه سيدي كان يحكي لابوي تشهد يابا اشهد
سمعوا صوته ط خوه كان ثاني واحد يفارق
سيدي كان عمي على الحيطه مال على الحيطه
وقال لي حط راسك بين ظهري يا عمي وبين
الحيطه وربنا ينجيكم يا عم ف خبطوا عمي
طخه عليه فاستشهد مباشر وفي كان شابين
مخليين نسايب كنا عنده استشهدوا بشكل
مباشر بعد عمي وفي كان صاحب الدار طخه
عليه فاستشهدوا كله انا تميت على الهيئه
اللي كنت فيها ظليت بحس انه ما اعلن اني
انا عايش
ضليت حوالي ثلاث ايام اللي قدرت اعمله
اجمع كل قرايبه في ناحيه واقعد غطيت وقعدت
عندهم بينهم كان القطل متعمد من ناحيه انه
المنطقه ملانه بالسكان مخضه
جدا وفي المقابل عننا مربع المدارس كانت
مليئه جدا جدا في النازحين كانت تحتوي عدد
كبير من النازحين وكانت كمنط امنه في
الشيخ رضوان انه هذا العدد كبير ممكن زي
ما تفضلت لك في الاول كان ممكن راح له